comment l'engouement pour les crimes de
jack l'éventreur a permis de mousser la
vente des journaux
[Musique]
alors nous sommes à l'été 2008 188 et un
homme commence à assassiner des
prostituées et non sur cinq au total
entre le mode ou le mois de novembre
1888 il les evs entre les crimes sont
sordides et très rapidement la presse
s'empare de l'histoire et ce criminel a
un nom jack l'éventreur
le public est fasciné par cette histoire
il a peur on opère en fait que les
crimes soient perpétrés dans d'autres
villes que londres en fait les crimes
ont lieu dans le secteur de whitechapel
dans l'est de londres un des quartiers
les plus pauvres ont fait de la ville à
la fin de l'époque victorienne
la nouvelle est tellement populaire
qu'on en parle dans les journaux aux
états unis et même au canada
alors comment vendre plus de journaux
lui donner un titre trouver des titres
accrocheurs c'est évident mais aussi
c'est de les vendre dans les rues c'est
comme ça que dès 1888
on a des forces nouvelles qui sont criés
dans les rues alors on dit on a trouvé
qu'ils étaient jack l'éventreur rondeurs
portrait de jack l'éventreur
on a de nouvelles théories sur
l'identité du criminel ce qui était
complètement fou et qui nuisent est en
fait aux enquêtes policières alors
beaucoup de jeune crieur qui travaillait
pour les journaux ont été arrêtées à
l'époque les coups de théâtre en 2018
puisque qu'on s'intéresse à cette
histoire de jack l'éventreur et surtout
aux lettres qui ont été envoyées aux
médias et aux journaux et surtout à la
police à l'époque on parle de plus de
209 lettres qui ont été envoyés en 1888
qui parlait des crimes alors en 2018 des
spécialistes ont analysé les lettres et
ont réalisé que la led dire bosse dans
laquelle on ne la première mention de
jack l'éventreur et la lettre ça c'est
déjà qu'ils étaient en fait des lettres
qui avait été écrit par un journaliste
mais que c'était le même journaliste qui
avait écrit les deux lettres
alors ce que ça nous démontre que même
le titre de jack l'éventreur est un fait
à l'époque une fausse nouvelle